what's going on there reject nation
koi's back with us after missing episode
five did you like episode five a lot of
crying all right and it wasn't here on
camera you you robbed the audience of
that reaction at home i just kept it to
myself we're at the finale of moon night
people thank you guys so much for
joining us on this journey it's been
amazing i'm sad to see it end right now
let's see what's in store let's see if
it sticks the landing guys full length
watch along as we see with the time code
are available for our super sexy rejects
at our patreon page thank you all for
joining us especially for the moon night
reactions means a lot follow koi on the
socials tick tock and youtube he's
posting all the time it's annoying but
it's good also leave a like that would
probably be the most beneficial thing
you can do for this video today thank
you guys so much and thank you to the
boys at prepper for helping us edit down
the highlights for moonlight thank you
john for being john john oh thanks for
being greg let's do it
[Music]
i'm sorry i'd have to be this way
mark specter stephen graham
whoever else might be in there
they keep hinting man yeah
oh no
oh no who wants to heal the world
[Music]
i don't need to show you my papers
[Music]
wait i am the goddess to wet it oh what
you should listen to the goddess perhaps
it's mark who's telling you to stop
what the hell is this
huh
he's dead and i'm talking to you through
dead people right
[Laughter]
it's time to go
[Music]
no one's questioning who this person is
this is the face of a good woman this is
like a very small group of people
[Music]
someone is trying to release amit
i don't trust her why
carl
i mean mark tried to tell you
clearly leave with the gods hidden from
mankind
[Music]
let's break them all
god fights
this is all so avoidable
nice
i love a good off-camera fight
choreography
oh here it goes
oh we're going big oh that's cool
wow
my name is
[Laughter]
come on do some marvel comedy
whom do i owe my gratitude your humble
disciple my goddess to whom you owe
nothing
your scales lack balance
oh oh
i had hoped
my penance might correct my imbalance
but i see now that's impossible
you are the avatar that i need
serve me
and you will find peace
oh yeah
do not let the pain of the past control
you
it's like the theme of this whole show
oh
i am in need of an avatar would you
layla
no
time has been cruel to you
indeed i cannot allow you to proceed
there's someone else here right
maybe it was that random person on our
team
you don't need him anymore mark so i get
to go on to eternal peace and he just
stays lost in the sand forever i'm not
good with that
think about this
[Music]
summon the cab
[Laughter]
lift
i'm jake lockley
just pulls up
looking pretty rough man
huh way back then
we were so young you saved me
i survived because i knew i wasn't alone
you're always there alive full of hope
and i tried to protect that and i failed
i couldn't protect you
oh
no man you didn't abandon me and all of
it although that field back there was
looking there
it's looking pretty good there's no way
now i'm gonna abandon you
oh buddy we're the only real superpower
wow
[Music]
that was so sweet
yes
[Music]
stephen
it's incredible these are two different
people to me
you came back the hell's wrong with you
well i did a whole little speech there
[Laughter]
oh kiss him kiss
god fight
cool
[Music]
oh
no
it's gotta be the both here
osiris you older
resurrection
oh nice
[Music]
here we go
haven't seen the moon knight sued and
truly moving in a while i knew you would
miss me taylor turned you down didn't
she amit has been freed
mark spector i need your help uh just
curious about something how's this whole
new arrangement gonna work then even
grant i was not speaking to you how's
this deal gonna work
you would negotiate now i would release
you both you'll have my work
how the heck are we gonna get to cairo
you forget little world
i am still the god of the night sky oh
all right you know what i think you can
take this one mark idiot
[Applause]
[Music]
oh god damn
it you changed your mind i would be
delighted to accept you as my avatar
your father was going to be over the
moon when he is
my father yes i met him but i took him
to the field of wreath
i'm doing this or what
i have a fabulous costume
they're seeing all kinds of things
lately over there
holy whoa perhaps judge everyone
[Music]
oh that's pretty terrifying actually
damn
[Music]
how do you find a giant alligator god
cool i love it
she looks great damn harold got slighted
awesome
oh
wow
[Music]
how did you get back
wow you look amazing what are you
wearing
[Laughter]
really jazzed about showing you these
new skill sets
[Music]
oh man down
there's the shot
oh nice
it's like a fight game yeah
swapped out
baby girl those people are getting
judged so hard
i feel so bad about my life souls are
triple condemned egyptian super hero i
am hell yeah
[Music]
it's like a ghostbusters stream
whoa
[Music]
get up jake
wow
that's a hell of a shot
wow
[Music]
[Music]
no chance mate
jake lockley has entered the game
grab my hands we can start the spell
now
[Music]
we cannot take the chance that amit
finds a way out she will kill again i
sound just like her you want them dead
[Music]
hmm do it yourself we're rushing a
little bit now
yeah
one episode left the finale rushing
[Music]
no
what if we disagree doc oh
it wasn't what if we believe something
different
oh
yeah you see that don't you
oh yeah i see it i see it why am i
bleeding well it is tempting to accept
your diagnosis doc
we'd rather go save the world like
dude mid-sentence accent swishing holy
[ __ ] hmm
i can't believe it worked
i can't believe you live in this
freaking mess
[Music]
what
feelings
processing
oh boy
the fact that we're all talking right
now is a good sign yeah
soak it in just absorb it
are we going to get a post-credits scene
i just want him driving a cab i think
the way of handling jake is exactly what
i want that's what i've been saying is
like just keep teasing him and then
bring it for the next season but like
keep it ominous and [ __ ] you and focus
on these two mm-hmm
and then this is
another yeah make it really
distinguished yeah maybe we'll get him
in a post-credits team
captain america
are they gonna make him spanish actually
oh that's cool that would totally work
knocked out man
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
makes me so happy
[Laughter]
mark spector truly believed that after
he and i parted ways i wanted his wife
to be my avatar and he has no idea how
troubled he truly is
oh no
he's a limbo driver instead of a cab
driver meet my friend
jay clarke
oh so conscious like using him but not
letting mark in on it yeah so he's the
true assassin mercenary like all
controlling
he doesn't even need a suit up
nope he takes them out as a cabbie limo
driver and i like that she was in the
suit because he didn't need to suit up
that's cool too like because they
changed steven grant to be like this
british
guy
who's not a billionaire
and then to change jake lockley from
like new york cabby driver to i don't
know honoring oscar isaac's roots a
little bit more so why did the the
randomly have an accent a couple times
in the in the psych ward to throw us off
dude that wasn't him that was i think
that was purposely done for the scenes i
said it i said it wasn't maybe i don't
know maybe i'm wrong
maybe he actually hasn't accepted speak
spanish all right well i was thinking
was that they were just doing that to
throw us off yeah because that's what i
thought like
to really distinguish better especially
when he's like switching in and out of
accents in a particular scene because it
sounds like mark has like a chicago
accent and it just comes out a little
bit more an extra enunciation of the of
the yeah that's one thing i chalked it
up too but i also thought i was wrong
too but it would also make sense for
something like that to come out in a
more drugged up state yeah i get boston
when i drink yeah yeah i said no i
thought that that's okay yeah it's just
like when you're a little bit more uh
uninhibited you know that'll come out of
your subconscious no it was a mistake on
oscar isaacs yeah no he's
too much he's messy with his acting if i
think of anything too much credit if i
have one complaint it's oscar isaac and
his messy vocal work this whole episode
was great other than oscar isaac's
acting yeah you really threw me yeah if
we could just redo this but like cast
somebody else pedro pascal it's a weird
feeling when my favorite moments that's
not my favorite moment but it's
definitely like
probably my favorite moment
yeah well it's not even like truly
opposed critics it's kind of the ending
like in its own way it's it's less of a
post-credit than most like it's an
actual it's key to the story
definitely in a way that i don't think
post-credit scenes generally are they
usually set up something as opposed to
this which concludes something show us
what's up something they're going to go
around hit manny people yeah yeah i hope
australia comes back
all right
let's discuss this show people chat all
right guys
we got microphones yeah because we got a
podcast where this goes up so i was like
hey let's
let's mic up
let's be professionals it's not gonna be
any different
it's gonna really improve the quality of
our conversation yeah i feel much more
entitled to just so much more like just
a drastic change from
okay audio to
drastically better audio this feels good
in my eardrums
just a massive switch
4k
now people will never be able to go back
to the old audio dolby sound um
so
this uh this episode
really showed us that
they're getting all their diversity out
of the way with one character here
he's got every uh an ethnicity and
nationality within him he's got a span
latino guy
a jewish guy
and then jefferson
british guy yeah that sounds good
you know what we haven't seen a lot of
british superheroes uh so look we talked
a little bit while i was prepping some
uh footage
and i was taking longer than usual and
so we're gonna have to naturally
regurgitate some of those conversations
uh not a lot we're gonna talk for like
five minutes about it but hey john yes
why don't you kick us off with your
thoughts on what you thought about the
moon night finale
be honest that's well that's required
absolutely the moon night finale i
thought was pretty decent i i liked it i
had a good time i really enjoyed the
imagination i enjoyed some of the crazy
circumstances that came to pass
uh i do feel like this could have easily
been a couple episodes worth of material
especially coming out of the last
episode that reached such wonderful
depths and heights of character
exploration felt like that stuff
definitely had to be fast-tracked in
this episode um so yeah it left me
wanting some things but i had a great
time so it's not like a slam dunk of an
ending but you know i mean it it got
there
i would definitely watch more i would be
thrilled to return to and expand this
world but but yeah it feels maybe a
little bit limited from this vantage
point
koi
i thought we got a lot of the things
we've been seeking but i do think we got
them very quickly i would have loved
another episode in the field of reads
and finding out what it was like for
mark spector to enjoy peace what his
experience of peace would even be beyond
that one beautiful shot where it looked
like they let oscar go to the spa but i
also think there was a beautiful moment
between the brothers that could have
been earned a little more by pushing it
now obviously they have a format of you
know six episodes at marvel but i think
the flexibility of letting the scripts
and the story they're telling breathe
and let it be seven let it be eight i
think what marvel the way marvel can
improve is by letting that flex you
should tell the story in the amount of
time the story takes to tell not in a
certain allocated amount of episodes you
shape your story around i think that's
kind of backwards the way they're doing
it right now and i think this episode
was the first time in the moon night
series i felt that in all of the marvel
series i felt a little bit of hurry up
and wait except loki i think loki is the
one that i thought the pacing stayed
consistent throughout and as such has my
favorite marvel finale and as such is
personally my favorite marvel show
because it has six episodes that all
feel justified whereas moon knight i
said if it stuck to landing was gonna be
my new favorite marvel show it's very
good i really really enjoyed it but i
think loki is a stronger arc and i do
think if moon knight had been perhaps
seven had been um you know more in the
psychology
at the finale and a little bit more
payoff it could have taken that number
one spot and as it stands now i think
it's my number two really enjoyed the
finale uh but i i did feel some wanting
yeah
yeah i i i'd echo everything you guys
said
i think i would say i liked it a little
bit less than you guys
because i'm just trying to push buttons
in the comments marvel hater now i just
want people this is the captain marvel
movies you can't talk like that
[Music]
engage in the comments
if you're listening on the only the
podcast
you can't see what i'm doing
they're
uh no i i would say that this episode
had some of the coolest moments
that i've seen in the entire series
they're like they're the fighting while
not long
there's not one really truly long fight
scene in any of these episodes is there
oh they're all brief everything's brief
this one he got two fight scenes
effectively i thought that was very
creative because they distinguished the
fighting between mr knight and moon
knight very well
and especially jake lockley
he was all
so that must have been jake was that
jake in the first episode i think so and
i also think it was jake obviously in
that one time they were both like what
was that but i think there's probably if
you re-watch it a couple episodes where
the bloodbath means it was jake i think
we saw jake probably
more than we think we did probably
probably there's going to be a lot of
people doing videos about that racking
hundreds of thousands of views on them
um and so yeah that i i think that some
of the fighting was some of the coolest
we've gotten
i actually was really worried once i saw
massive ahmed like growing ahmed was
like oh crap i was like my first thought
and then as it progressed i actually
thought it was really cool cage you
fight it was kaiju does how do you say
it
george takei
george occasions fight
uh yeah i thought that was a really cool
fight um i mean it wasn't like the
coolest fight ever but it was better
than i expected it to be i like some of
the phasing of even just consciou on the
ground level of how he moved there uh so
yeah i like when like they go on giant
and you know there's that slow motion
and they swoop the feel the scale yeah i
love them when they swim the car was so
tiny that was one of my favorite shots
well that was a good uh
establisher that like oh yeah these are
physical forms and they are wreaking
havoc over here
yeah yeah i thought that was really
great
layla
i like the acoustic version better from
uh eric clapton unplugged more than um
the actual rock and roll edition wow
that's right
he's an artist i'm an artist because
i've named one of the two eric clapton
um so yeah i thought layla's uh costume
was great and um full disclosure
[Music]
but if you guys know who the character
is from a comic book please let us know
uh which would be very interesting for
the mcu to
have like a a like a a another female
hero we don't have too many lady heroes
in the mcu girls get it done an egyptian
hero and if it's going to be completely
original and i honestly i think it is
and i feel like this is a really cool
way to start introducing new heroes in
this direction like harley quinn came
through and the animated series and then
became a comic book
so like having a tv show introduces
through women through through the tv
show comic book artists don't like
writing females but i i feel like that's
a really like smart way for the mcu to
start to be unique from the comics yeah
yeah very true i thought her powers were
really cool it was wonder woman ask sure
um at the same time it still felt like
it's its own thing i like the use of the
flight the wings
um
i i was a bit concerned that it was
going to be inside once i said that and
then i saw where my thoughts were going
and then i heard what some of the
comments might say and i'm going to stop
there
i'm going to say this instead oh no i'm
going to say what i'm saying i'm going
to stop you from saying what you're
probably going to say some of you
for people out there was that i was
concerned that it was going to be layla
was going to save the whole day
and now i know a lot of people might go
oh freaking woke agenda somewhere
yeah and i didn't that's not where i was
going with i just thought about i might
undercut the show a little bit uh just
for the fact that your title character
is not the one who's the hero or like
actually saves the day but that's
something i did like about this as well
like it gave us the the arc
of the character fully stephen and mark
coming together embracing each other as
brothers and learning to literally just
live
during the day like with each other they
just they know how to alternate back and
forth it kind of
kind of happened a little quick to me
and so that one more episode i really
would love it it should have been two
episodes like
if you if you play the episodes back to
back of five and six stephen's gone for
like 15 minutes that's it as opposed to
like having the reeds having the
breakdown having the bond having the
development of the two voices having all
of that take longer have the psychology
back in the psych ward have that
developed have the harrow stuff last a
little bit longer have the fight work in
the same way probably the same pace but
just letting the moments breathe other
than the fights i feel like the fight
was the right amount of time i feel like
the fight especially the switching
between mr night and moon night was so
special because it was so rapidly
between the two if it was longer it
wouldn't have felt special as long and
then juxtaposing the small contained
fight with the kaiju fight was really
cool visually so i loved all that but
whenever it wasn't fighting i did feel
like they were like we gotta get back to
the fighting and i was like but there's
so much psychology that we were
resolving here
yeah i didn't feel much uh i wasn't
really hooked like nothing was really
like
latching into my emotions during this
episode you know and the rest of the
series i have them
other than the probably you know the
part when they do actually bond with
each other i mean uh where mark does
rescue stephen in the sand well yeah i
was going to say this was and then this
isn't to spoil multiverse madness i had
a similar kind of complaint about that
movie was that this kept giving me these
scenes where i was like this is so
wonderful like i love that back and
forth between stephen and mark or even
the back and forth between layla and
konchu i thought was great where she's
like i'm not gonna be your slave like
there are all these moments that hint at
some really great character unpacking
and even for harrow i think he got
slighted maybe the most in this episode
because i again have been loving ethan
hawk's performance and he makes that
ultimate sacrifice and there are all
those moments where he's like hey i i
have dedicated my life to you but you
know what if my scales aren't uh
balanced i accept my fate like i loved
those bits and then you know he becomes
amit's avatar and then pretty much from
there it's just like well okay so we
gotta bind her to him and there's the
physical stakes and as long as we can
kill them we'll be good and uh yeah it
was one of those things where i feel
like it's all there it just could have
been more graceful and it could have
come down to more than just the plotting
yeah i still feel like it got a little
too big for my tastes
too big too too quickly yeah yeah cause
like ahmet uh for some reason just
doesn't leave much of an impression to
on me and what and why does her avatar
not get a cool outfit i don't know
she's just gonna stay in the same ropes
at first when she showed up i was like
interesting and then she started talking
and i was like
yeah that i feel like this build up to
ahmed being unleashed really wasn't
anything special i i didn't other than
like cool visual of giant konchu and
giant ahmet the character of amen and
the build-up to ultimately what she was
doing i really think this needed to be
two episodes
it really would have changed everything
it didn't drop my stomach the way i
wanted it to yeah no nor what did it
feel as it didn't start feeling actually
scary or menacing until she was like
we're judging everyone in egypt right
now
a bunch of moments that were cool like
that like there were a bunch of moments
where we got excited that like i i want
to give the the episode a lot more
credit for those things that did work
it's just the major major thing of
wishing it was more
length is is i the undercurrent like we
can say we love you know the emotional
ties of seeing that giant rapture we can
say we enjoyed the emotional connection
between them two and the fights and all
those things but without the time
between those moments it did feel like
that's all we can talk about well yeah
it's like there's
there's moments and then there's scenes
there's like there's a big difference
between them and i think that a lot of
the
the actual scenes were just not having
the effect that i think they were
intending that that were desired you
know like there's a lot i feel like you
could pick a part here and there's a lot
i think you can isolate and look back on
and go well i appreciate that like you
brought up the scene
for podcast listeners john brought up
the scene because that's me about uh you
know like when konchu is is debating
with layla
i do like that reveal though of kancho
being like i never wanted that girl
yeah that was nice the jake reveal i
don't i think this might be one of the
first times we had the show end in a
post-credits scene we were talking that
this isn't like a continuation into the
future and further it is obviously
setting up things but it's also kind of
the end of the show and it's interesting
to do that after some credits and i
don't know if i've seen that well i
think what's neat about that reveal i
know we're kind of hopping around all
over the place here but that you know
that's kind of the vibe that's left here
uh is that
konchu is
he has a negotiation with mark and
um stephen you know and then it makes
mark and steven feel like they're
finally in control of the situation with
konchu
and then the ending reveal shows you no
they're not
they're not and they probably have never
been in control and they're not even
aware of it there's only like teas like
by now they should be like there's a
third personality in me they have to at
least somewhat deduce that they haven't
even said that to themselves
this is the second time maybe that's the
defense mechanism like maybe they're
blocking that much yeah yeah i mean you
get it here in that one bit of like that
definitely wasn't me that wasn't me i do
like that he spent he speak he's a
spanish-speaking character because uh
you know oscar isaac being cuban in
guatemala and totally did not look that
up in between setting up microphones uh
him being cube in guatemalan and being
able to represent that here is awesome
also the ability that he has to go
between languages and accents in the
same sentence is staggering some of the
acting in this obviously the whole show
we've been praising the acting but every
time he transfers in between moments and
in this one now that he's doing it in
real time like he's actually both
steven and mark live at us incredible
work like truly staggering yeah
definitely how do you guys feel about
hero overall as a villain throughout the
series
i think it felt like ethan hawk
personally his character i really liked
him more in the psych ward more than i
did as actually arthur harrow i like
what he represented inside of mark and
steven's mind more but
i know you really
yeah i clicked on him a lot throughout
this series so curious to know like how
you feel about arthur harrow in total
yeah i mean mvp in term one of the mvps
in terms of performance i mean like you
know all the flowers to oscar isaac
absolutely but i really do love what
ethan hawk has brought to this and
and again i liked the notes with him
that carried through this but i i gotta
kind of agree with you that the most
interesting and and part of the
interesting thing about the way he is
the doctor in you know the the the you
know
mental asylum you know sort of spiritual
way station is based on your association
with him on earth but yeah i i feel like
that is the most interesting stuff when
it comes right down to it and i kept
wishing that there was
again more time to explore
him
personally because there's so much
really interesting connective tissue
between him and mark steve and jake etc
his relation to khanshu and everything
and you know he gets kind of a raw deal
with with amit and i would have liked to
have i don't know
it's it's it's interesting
it's a badass and very kind of
cold-blooded ending that they give to
him but it's like oh he's dead now i
guess
that's that
i
don't
really like that cliche anymore
where character kills people constantly
and then when it comes down to the big
baddie they become a moral hero and
[Music]
and i especially
didn't like it here because that was
ridiculously rushed he's been killing so
many people like he is
constantly
in this episode alone he's like steps
but until the guy that's trying to kill
the planet yeah no he's still well and
yeah and the fact that there's so much
of the conflict between stephen and mark
is steven going dude you're a savage you
killing cold blood we can't do that
anymore like that's cool that's fine
except this episode also then goes to
swap that round and go well mark's
actually not that much of a savage the
stephen lockley he's the savage so it
kind of muddies that up too
that scene felt very perfunctory to me
in the way that was handled and it just
was just like get the get the lines out
of the way that's how it like read to me
in the moment just so quick and
especially after we had just had this
really cool moment of introducing a new
hero and having this really cool like
power couple moment to have that
undermined by this very traditional oh
this is a hero moment it felt like oh
we're subverting expectations and
expectations and and that the rest of
the show hadn't felt that way for me
that's very good point because i
personally really liked how you know
jake lockley you don't see him take out
all the bad guys you don't see although
it might have been cool to do one of
those like fight club montages
where you like go back and you see
speaking spanish in the because i told
you when he popped in the cab and he was
like what's that accent i would love to
see him speaking spanish
i'm killing five people
it's the el mariachi there's like a
whole robert rodriguez movie that
happens
yeah that's episode eight at once
borrowing from boba fett i didn't i i
didn't uh didn't care for that scene um
but because you could have come down to
something interesting between the two
avatars and between again somebody who
has known khan shu's service but also
now under ahmet service like you could
have made an interesting
conflict that also plays off of or
bounces off of what is literally
gigantically happening backdrop harrow
didn't get the chance to really manifest
his being the official avatar nor did we
really have the actual conflict of the
avatars greeting ethan because they got
killed off camera so like you've set up
this thing where ethan hawk has been
forgiven inexplicably because he lost
grizzlies like yo he's doing some stuff
they're like we don't believe you oscar
isaac and then he marches in they're
like oh i guess he was right dead off
screen
i would have liked to have had some more
there to me the biggest disappointment
of all this the biggest disappointment
is that it did exactly what i was
worried this finale would do which was
be go big have a lot of action but we
had five episodes prior even the third
episode which i personally thought a lot
of people loved that episode i thought
that was the weakest of the of the five
i really felt like the thing they
dropped the ball on the most was they
dropped everything about conversations
psychology and they just went for big
you know they had that one great scene
where you do see you know mark and
steven entering back into their own mind
working together beautiful defeat you
know like overcoming the manipulative
the psychiatrist therapist uh in their
own mind
i thought that was a really great
acceptance scene uh as on top of it all
that was a really good one but
like all the they had such good debates
and conversations and and philosophical
existential conversations woven in
throughout this series in so many ways
and like discussions uh even with arthur
harrow with layla with mark with stephen
and then
the gods debated in episode three at
least you know discussing this and then
here it's just like zip zip bang bang
bang you know
to me that's my one division problem is
i really really loved wanda vision and
there was literally a transition from
ship of theseus to punch vision yeah it
goes very quickly episode six felt like
the marvel episode and i like marvel but
if you're gonna let me have something
that's a psychological and philosophical
conversation and then suddenly pivot to
punching that's not the show and like to
me that was if this could have kept the
punching but also kept the psychology if
there was one more episode that's that's
the balance they gotta strike and that's
why this had to have been two episodes
and i don't think every show was success
loki six episodes yeah it is yeah wow
it's i think it's a structure issue and
one division is eight
yep they're shorter
that's true well they grow because yeah
they start out being like 30 25 30
minutes and they become like 45 50 55.
and i really think that like you need
like that flexibility worked and i think
moon knight could have used a little bit
of that like let this be seven this felt
like studio notes in a lot of way of
like we got to go back it was still a
superhero show so
you know let's let's get a little bit
more lively here you know like with the
whole thing when they're
the the stakes of when stephen and mark
are reunited and they're walking back to
to get out and there were still so many
cool things but yeah it's just like
that's the thing and then the
the cyrus the boat and then the freaking
yeah i'm gonna stop the waves like this
kind of it starts to feel a little like
a disney movie yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's silly so yeah and it's also and if
koi's having issues you know this you
know what you guys i'm trying to be
[Laughter]
before i turn into steven
um so yeah
you know it's like last episode a lot of
these episodes just like are so
invigorating that
no matter how tired i am they just spark
a thought process and here i'm just like
my feelings i'm left with are
some of the coolest moments like the
action was really cool like that was
really getting me a lot of the time
and and it was also that feeling too of
like
i really want to keep loving this so i'm
really trying to give in to the the cool
even more but then by the time it wraps
up i'm but it literally was the scene
when uh mark is like i'm not gonna kill
him you do it you know at that moment
was when i was like okay yeah this this
has totally lost me at that moment
for my for me like the the problem was
how good the rest of the show was that i
my expectations were at that consistent
a that like high
concept a really interesting
thought-provoking situation and then for
the last episode to be
you know a b b minus it's not bad it's
not you know uh it's just bel the
average show is not even a b for me but
the average of this has been an a so a b
feels like a downgrade so comparatively
is the problem and that's what's hard
about these six episode shows is if
you've got this momentum with five and
then six doesn't stick the landing it
affects your whole experience and i do
think there could have been a bit of a
different way to handle the
what was ref what was left of the story
to tell especially after
that remarkable fifth five man well
because it makes the fifth episode then
feel like it's out of a separate show
and got dropped into this more sort of
fun and swashbuckling thing
and if we could have had that because i
feel like five in generals stands
separate from all of them because they
all have a certain reliance on adventure
and we got to keep things moving and
stuff and we're building the psychology
and they're all crescendos there and it
doesn't feel like we gracefully came out
of that crescendo into this you know it
feels like we started in one show we had
that fifth episode to really kind of
flood it with this saturation of emotion
and then the last one kind of ends up
somewhere in the middle kind of like
floating in the middle of those things
i'm curious re-watching it now that i
have the expectations of the last
episode being so action-packed if it
would be feel better now that you know
like now that i know that's the route if
the whole show
you know knowing where it lands feels
better i just don't think you can get
back to light
to lighter without feeling a little bit
of of that kind of
without feeling the difference in the
weight you know because this does just
feel like a lighter thing at the end and
there is something too about that that i
think narrows the scope or makes the
scope again feel a little bit more like
a cartoon and i think you know in
reveling in some of those harsher darker
more challenging emotions you can then
help legitimize all of the crazy magical
circumstances around you but the faster
the circumstances have to unfold the
more everything starts to feel like a
rollercoaster ride yeah i like what you
just said about lighter and darker i
wish we had a couple moments to like
appreciate the fact that that so many
people were dying in the streets of
egypt and we were seeing these people
like judging each other and they were
seeing like this massive horrific event
and it was like 30 seconds like we
didn't get time to realize how traumatic
that was we didn't get time to realize
like these people are judging their
neighbor and killing them and that's all
happening and that we've set up the
whole show to that like that this is the
revelations we were like waiting for
ahmed to come back for then i was like
we gotta get back to the fight and i
just i wanted to live there more
that's i just keep i sound like a broken
record i just want more and i love that
this is my problem but like i want more
yeah
yeah
well
here we are again another marvel from
now good
moments some great moments
in the finale
a lot of great moments overall where you
guys ranked the shows
oh boy
um i like ranking stuff i'm a list guy
i'm a virgo how many shows we got now
low-key
i'd still give the edge to moon knight
falcon
this one yeah you got two left yeah
there it is yeah
i was letting you get there then episode
four of what if of doctor strange
and then what if
that's one little category
it would probably be loki one division
this and falcon of winter soldier can
grapple for the next slot then uh what
if hawkeye so this is a little slightly
above for me it goes loki this
one division for me but those three are
like this beautiful like different you
know top category and then falcon winter
soldier
hawkeye what if
man this is tough because this one i
really
i don't know why i feel especially
as much as there were like some really
cool exciting moments it's one of those
things that the more i think about it
the more
i feel like i'm in the sand
just like yeah oh
i'm feeling empty and cold
because i think it hurts more when the
show proves it can sing and it can be so
great and then it doesn't yeah so when
we talk about it i'm like oh i'm i'm
withering away and i'm over here going
like i like that moon night mr knight
fight and i really like the dichotomy
between the sizes and i really like the
moment where their brothers and bonded
again and i'm gonna stay in the happy
space i'm going i'm over here like you
know
somewhere out there there's a timeline
where this was incredible
somewhere there's a timeline where
there's seven episodes so that was very
exciting seven episodes every show on
the seven episode timeline there's a
multiverse koi very excited about the
seventh episode of moon night yeah yeah
all right well what did you guys at
least had fun at the time i was watching
it with you guys yeah that's what i'll
say i'll leave it there it was fun at
the time of watching it
and the less i talk about it the more i
can just appreciate
the enjoyment i had i wasn't bored the
real fist of conscious the friends we
made along the way you see the only real
problem i'd have is if i was bored but i
wasn't bored so
if i'm not bored then all right fine
i would rather want more of what we're
seeing which i do than want less of what
we're seeing which i don't i would
absolutely be excited for a season two
100 yeah i think we can all agree there
the imagination and the tonal expansion
alone is is worth the effort i'd also
love to see him pop into other different
tones and how weird it would be if moon
knight was just suddenly like hanging
out spiderman and deadpool sharon have
you earned this mics we're talking way
longer than usual definitely good luck
at it
we like our choices here we are
[ __ ] for you guys
you got no editing
oh you don't wanna settle yeah
guys
bye love you all bye everyone
bye everyone